mais si certains pays voient leur taux
de vaccination de ramper ce n'est pas le
cas de la russie où seul un tiers de la
population est vaccinée conséquence la
situation sanitaire se dégrader les
chiffres s'envolent un nouveau record
ces dernières 24 heures 41 à 1335 cas de
contamination et 1188 décès ont été
recensés on fait le point avec notre
correspondant à moscou entre une cliente
la personne en charge des questions de
santé au sein de l'exécutif a fait
savoir que le recours aux qr code pour
accéder aux bâtiments des institutions
gouvernementales et est désormais
appliquée quasiment à travers tout le
pays presque toutes les régions russes
sont introduits les qr codes pour
fréquenter les institutions publiques
service de restauration et
établissements culturels il est
important que l'authenticité de ces
codes qu'il s'agisse du certificat de
rétablissement du certificat de
vaccination ou du test pcr soit
soigneusement vérifié sur le terrain la
campagne de vaccination doit être
intensifiée si l'on veut empêcher la
propagation du virus et parallèlement
toute tentative de falsification des
certificats de vaccination doit être
déjoués c'est de ces actions que la date
du dénouement de la pandémie en russie
dépend
le maire de moscou estime pour sa part
que la situation sanitaire dans la
capitale russe tend à se stabiliser en
effet le nombre de nouveaux cas
quotidiens serait passé de 8000 à 6000
en simplement quelques jours l'effet des
jours chômés ne devrait être perceptible
qu'à la fin de cette semaine ou plutôt
de la semaine prochaine quand les
moscovites reprendront le travail c'est
à ce moment là que nous constaterons la
situation réelle mais si on se réfère à
la dynamique de morbidité et
d'hospitalisation nous voyons que la
situation est déjà plus ou moins stable
aujourd'hui on détecte environ 6000 cas
de co vite par jour alors que récemment
vous vous souvenez qu'on avait atteint
un niveau de 8000 cas par jour nous
espérons que la situation s'améliorera
bien sûr les jours chômés auront un
certain impact eu égard à la diminution
des échanges sociaux la mesure n'est pas
facile mais elle vaut le coup la semaine
chaumet décrétée par les autorités qui a
commencé le 30 octobre dernier va
s'achever ce dimanche 7 novembre les
autorités locales peuvent cependant
étendre cette période et c'est le choix
qu'ont fait par exemple les ré lyon 2
kursk smolensk et tcheliabinsk